[Music]
in 1881 dr. William Halstead rushed to
help his sister Minnie who was emerging
after childbirth
he quickly inserted a needle into his
arm withdrew his own blood and
transferred it to her
after a few uncertain minutes she began
to recover Halstead
didn't know how lucky they'd gotten his
transfusion only worked because he and
his sister happened to have the same
blood type something that isn't
guaranteed even among close relatives
blood types hadn't been discovered by
Halstead time though people had been
experimenting with transfusions for
centuries
mostly unsuccessfully in 1667 a French
physician named jean-baptiste Denis
became the first to try the technique on
a human Denis transfused sheep's blood
into Antoine mal wah
a man likely suffering from psychosis in
the hopes that it would reduce his
symptoms afterward
muwah was in good spirits but after a
second transfusion he developed a fever
severe pain in his lower back intense
burning in his arm and he urinated a
thick black liquid
though nobody knew it at the time these
were the signs of a dangerous immune
response unfolding inside his body this
immune response starts with the
production of proteins called antibodies
which distinguished the body's own cells
from intruders they do so by recognizing
the foreign proteins or antigens
embedded in an intruders cell membrane
antibodies latch on to the antigens
signaling other immune cells to attack
and destroy the foreign cells the
destroyed cells are flushed from the
body in urine in extreme cases the
massive breakdown of cells causes clots
in the bloodstream that disrupt the flow
of blood to vital organs overload the
kidneys and cause organ failure
fortunately deniz patients survived the
transfusion but after other
cross-species transfusions proved fatal
the procedure was outlawed across Europe
falling out of favor for several
centuries
it wasn't until 1901 that Austrian
physician Karl launch diner discovered
blood types the crucial step in the
success of human to human blood
transfusions he noticed that when
different types were mixed together they
formed clots this happens when
antibodies latch onto cells with foreign
antigens causing blood cells to clump
together but if the donor cells are the
same blood type as the recipient cells
the donor cells won't be flagged for
destruction and won't form clumps by
1907 doctors were mixing together small
amounts of blood before transfusing it
if there were no clumps the types were a
match this enabled them to save
thousands of lives
laying the foundation for modern
transfusions up to this point all
transfusions had occurred in real time
directly between two individuals that's
because blood begins to clot
almost immediately after coming into
contact with air a defense mechanism to
prevent excessive blood loss after
injury in 1914 researchers discovered
that the chemicals sodium citrate
stopped blood coagulating by removing
the calcium necessary for clot forming
situated blood could be stored for later
use the first step in making large-scale
blood transfusions possible in 1916 a
pair of American scientists found an
even more effective anticoagulant called
heparin which works by deactivating
enzymes that enable clotting we still
use heparin today at the same time
American and British researchers
developed portable machines that could
transport donor blood onto the
battlefields of World War one combined
with a newly discovered heparin medics
safely stored and preserved litres of
blood
wheeling it directly onto the
battlefield to transfuse wounded
soldiers after the war this crude
portable box would become the
inspiration for the modern-day blood
bank a fixture of hospitals around the
world did you know that horseshoe crab
blood plays an essential role in the
medical industry find out why we're so
dependent on this ancient creature with
this video or continue understanding
your circulatory system by learning more
about blood types
[Music]